breastfeed for two years or longer
that's what the american academy of
pediatrics now suggests this is the
first time in 10 years the aap has
changed its breastfeeding guidance we
delve into why
i truly think that this is you know
probably been a long time coming dr
kiriji singha of siena pediatrics in
henderson referring to the american
academy of pediatrics updated policy
recommendations published in this
month's issue of pediatrics the aap
still encouraging breastfeeding of
infants exclusively in the first six
months of their lives before introducing
other food to complement nutrition but
it also encourages mothers who choose to
continue breastfeeding after solid foods
are introduced for two years or longer
as opposed to just one year with the
formula shortage i think it just
reiterates yes in this you know
situation with the lack of formula you
are totally fine to medically support a
child they'll get their nutrition
through breastfeeding as well as food
from that one to two years of age and
here's why in addition to providing key
nutrients to infants research has shown
links between breastfeeding and
decreased rates of lower respiratory
tract infections obesity severe diarrhea
ear infections and decreased risk of
sudden infant death syndrome
breastfeeding beyond one year and for up
to two years has been associated with
protections for the mother against high
blood pressure diabetes and breast and
ovary cancers but the authors of the new
guidance also acknowledge that some
parents can't breastfeed or prefer not
to sometimes real medical reasons we
have to step in and help the baby to get
supplements as like in the case of
formula um to help them so we're not
saying we're against breastfeeding but
we have to also look at the best
interest of the baby
now for mothers breastfeeding even
longer dental health is also critical
when your child starts getting their
first tooth they're at risk of cavities
dr weijie singha says stop breast or
bottle feeding overnight at that point
switch to water and start brushing your
baby's teeth